[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrar
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
un tema del que se está hablando mucho
últimamente y que va a marcar el futuro
bueno quizá el futuro y hasta aquí el
llamado metaverso un ecosistema virtual
inmersivo donde podemos reunirnos con
familia o amigos hacer ejercicio
trabajar jugar ir a un concierto comprar
prácticamente cualquier actividad a la
que se tenga acceso en el mundo real es
decir toda una revolución tecnológica
que abre innumerables cuestionamientos
políticos éticos filosóficos y
culturales
para explicarlo mejor nos acompañan hoy
israel ayala periodista especializado en
nuevas tecnologías bienvenido israel
hola muchas gracias benjamin se va que
es director de la agencia blogs agencia
de marketing 3.0 que trabaja en
proyectos precisamente de traverso
bienvenido bien llamado buenos días y
tomasson periodista presentador del
espacio anti complot de la cadena el pse
y especialista en redes sociales
bienvenido encantado estoy aquí el
metaverso el futuro ya está aquí hoy en
primera plana
[Música]
vamos a ver si lo explicamos bien de qué
se trata esto del meta verso se trata de
un espacio como internet pero con una
capacidad de interacción y una sensación
de presencia mucho mayor de la que se
tiene a día de hoy en la red permite el
usuario ponerse unas gafas e interactuar
y moverse dentro de un mundo virtual y
con la percepción psicológica de que
realmente se está en ese mundo el meta
de eso será un mundo tridimensional
generado por ordenador un gemelo digital
de la realidad en la que podremos
reproducir todas las dinámicas sociales
de la vida real mis invitados van a
saber explicar hoy mejor de qué se trata
qué retos tiene y que incertidumbres
plantea al futuro el futuro que ya es
casi el presente pero antes vamos a
repasar algunas portadas que nos deja la
prensa revista epsilon ahí lo tienen
bienvenidos al metaverso el primer mundo
paralelo business magazine metaverso
como la inteligencia artificial va a
transformar la economía la prensa
generalista también ya va publicando
muchos artículos sobre esta temática
como este del país el metaverso el mundo
virtual donde mark zuckerberg quiere que
compres te diviertas y trabajes y
terminamos con esta the time que habla
por sí sola la cara y ese mensaje de si
está seguro de eliminar la aplicación de
facebook vamos a hablar hoy de las dudas
éticas y políticas y del manejo de
nuestras vidas que puede generar en todo
esto la corporación de mark zuckerberg
lo primero vamos a ver es a él vamos
empecemos por la definición cómo podemos
definir metaverso mira una cosa muy
curiosa es que depende a quién le
preguntes le va a dar una declaración de
que es el metaverso hay diez
definiciones de metaverso pero para
hacerlo muy fácil de entender son
universos digitales en donde hay tres
factores principales la realidad virtual
la realidad aumentada la creación de
avatares y donde interactúan ciertos
productos digitales o conceptos
digitales como por ejemplo los tokens no
fungibles los ntn df y donde se hacen
interacciones virtuales entre cosas que
son a veces reales a veces
digitales
ven llaman cuál es el origen de todo
esto permita ver sus ojos donde empezó
porque usted ya lleva tiempo trabajando
en ello es la origen viene de la
evolución natural del internet para mí
el origen es la evolución del mundo que
conocemos en internet que se traslada en
un nuevo internet
viene de lo que hemos conocido en las
redes sociales con las comunidades en
entornos que pertenece a empresas
grandes ahora la evolución de esto son
comunidades y mundos virtuales
descentralizados que no hay ninguna
empresa detrás de ellos toma trabajo un
montón con redes sociales no sé si esto
le parece como la continuación o ya un
salto cualitativo que se va un poco de
este mundo bueno es muy difícil del
cielo antes de ir al arte de una cierta
forma dentro de este mente verso estoy
de acuerdo con benjamin así que parece
una
algo natural que la tecnología la
tecnología progresa y así sigue sigue
avanzando no así que el metaverso es
como una especie de sueño el tecnológico
que hemos visto a veces en en películas
o en libros es como el futuro digital
virtual el problema es que todavía no
hemos encontrado la manera de
aplica las leyes humanas en el antiguo
facebook y en ese nuevo mundo como vamos
a hacer así que es una verdadera
pregunta y luego vamos a hablar de esa
parte oscura de sedar site pero antes me
gustaría preguntarles para que lo
entiendan nuestra audiencia que vamos a
poder hacer dentro del metaverso en la
práctica la vida cotidiana israelí pues
muchísimas cosas desde ir a un concierto
a hacer videoconferencias con tu avatar
comunicarte con las personas que están
al otro lado del mundo prácticamente
todo lo que puedes hacer en la vida real
lo puedes hacer en un universo
metaversos el metaverso es un universo
como si fuera uno real pero con cositas
que puedes hacer demás y puedes crear tu
avatar tu avatar puede hacer ciertas
cosas por ejemplo si vas a tener una
reunión con tu con tu empresa pues vas a
tener los avatares de tus colegas o vas
a poder verlos a ellos en cómo son en
fin es es como un universo lleno de
posibilidades no casi todo lo que tú te
imaginas lo puedes hacer
en llamas que podemos que podamos a
poder hacer una vida práctica que un
montón de consenso por supuesto pero
bueno para poner algunas trampas habrá
nuevas cosas seguramente se van a
desarrollar nuevas cosas pero al
principio es para reemplazar las métodos
clásicas de sociabilización de
entertainment de diversión y de
entretenimiento de ecommerce también
porque el mundo de compra online va a
ser revolucionado también en el
metaverso otra vez sigo con esta
evolución de todas esas actividades que
hacemos al día de hoy en un nuevo
entorno vamos a poner un ejemplo
práctico que nos presentaba el propio
mark zuckerber en su vídeo de
presentación de el metaverso hace tan
solo unas semanas por ejemplo lo hemos
nombrado aquí ir a un concierto con una
amiga que vive en las antípodas de donde
vivimos nosotros vamos a verlo
radiónica grandes art concerts aircraft
world
worth it peter weir
[Música]
granier bueno esto es el mundo
zuckerberg porque pero luego vamos a
hablar también de esta parte del barça y
no de la parte negra que tiene todo esto
toma además de estas oportunidades que
estamos hablando qué peligros y desafíos
potenciales tiene este mundo bueno
primero hemos
descubrirlo en los últimos años que
facebook
estaba en capacidad de cambiar nuestra
visión de la realidad
puede cambiar a veces estas opiniones de
la gente y ponernos frente a falsas
novedades o cosas que nos cambian
nuestra visión del mundo y en el viejo
facebook
no hemos encontrado manera de hacer más
transparencia de entender cómo
funcionaba en la máquina
el problema que nos viene es que sucede
la misma cosa de manera mucho más
amplificada en el metaverso porque de la
misma manera que facebook no nos quiere
decir porque veamos tal o tal cosa o
estamos nos propone está lotes al
contenido el metaverso va sucede en la
misma cosa así que hay un riesgo de que
esta visión un poco mágica de el
metaverso cambia nuestra visión del
mundo benjamin hablaba de esta nueva
manera de relacionarnos no de
socializarnos si estás súper imaginar
que estamos viviendo en un juego vídeo
no es un poco como estar en la
playstation
el tema es que la vida no real no es un
juego hay verdaderos peligros hay
verdaderos populistas personas que
quieren
mentirnos
quizás atacarnos no lo sé pero la vida
real tiene manera de protegernos leyes
y en este nuevo mundo virtual no hay es
un poco el far west no así que tenemos
que encontrar un sheriff y que el
sheriff haga su trabajo también el plan
es el sheriff puede ser mark zuckerberg
y facebook hay críticas analizando la
prensa del poder que tiene una sola
corporación en algo que va a determinar
nuestras vidas y si es como conveniente
que esto sea así israel exactamente
porque como en todas las tecnologías con
el surgimiento de nuevas tecnologías
pues la regulación viene siempre después
entonces quiénes son los que regulan por
ejemplo los metaversos pues van a ser
las mismas empresas que van a crear este
universo porque bueno ahorita hablamos
de meta bears es algo que vivía que está
en boga que es muy pero pues también
está en una etapa que es sino germinal
pues que si es también de concepción de
ver cómo se va a desarrollar cómo va a
ser la interoperabilidad de
interconexión de meta ver cómo va a ser
la regulación tenemos actualmente por
ejemplo en estas fases de prueba hemos
visto ya casos de acoso sexual en el met
haberes que fue reciente casos de acoso
sexual en el metaverso laro con un
avatar al que le tocaron los senos por
ejemplo eso cómo se va a regular o sea
lo vas a sancionar con las normas que
están en el mundo real o vas a crear
unas normas para el mundo digital no y
que lo va a hacer los estados-nación que
tenemos en el mundo real o las
corporaciones empezando por facebook que
van a dominar el metaverso me llama
justamente esta tecnología permite un
nuevo orden para todas estas preguntas
el mundo descentralizado permite lo que
se llama los de ao son organizaciones
descentralizadas que permite a cada
usuario un miembro del proyecto de dar
su opinión de dar su dos como un ser
holder lo haría en una empresa entonces
las regulaciones dentro de cada meta a
ver si proyectos se harán mediante estos
nuevos sistema de gubernamental que se
llaman los díaz out el primer también
que se plantea es claro el que domina
que es facebook no sé si quieren mucha
poca regulación en un artículo de the
times
el analista de tecnología benedict evans
caracterizó la motivación de facebook de
esta manera si hay algo después de los
teléfonos inteligentes facebook quiere
ser propietario y no inquilino están de
acuerdo con que esta ambición de la que
depende tanto la humanidad presenta
rasgos de monopolio el problema de
facebook es que es una empresa privada
como lo has dicho pero que ahora se
convirtió en una especie de de espacio
público no es ahí que se hace la
conversación claro es ahí es privada
pero nos va afectar a todos pasa a lo
público eso por esas voces que plantean
trocear a facebook en varias partes y de
la misma manera que aunque no estás
inscrito en facebook facebook
en el diálogo público y la conversación
política por ejemplo claro base a la
misma en el metaverso así que si no
estás en el metaverso también el
metaverso va a tener una influencia en
tu vida real y eso es un verdadero
problema que no es solamente el tema de
facebook es también la misma cosa de los
gafas quizás tenemos que decir ahora lo
llaman bien google amazon meta apple y
microsoft que eran antiguamente gafas
con facebook ese cambio de nombre que
apuntaba toma que está muy bien traer o
meta que es el hay muchas personas que
están muy crítico porque hay que iniciar
algo para la gente que no nos están
escuchando es que el momento en el cual
el facebook que está vendiendo nosotros
el metaverso es el peor momento de
crisis de la empresa es el momento en el
cual francés alguien
wiesel blower no sé cómo se dice en
español el lanzador de alerta quizá
enlazado
nos dio a ver lo que se pasa adentro de
facebook una empresa donde los empleados
no entienden el algoritmo donde mark
zuckerberg tienen todo el poder
todos estos todas esas críticas en su
informe scan salida de más sobre
instagram todas las críticas es el
momento que aprovecha facebook para
hacer todo este cambio vamos a seguir
hablando de todo la vuelta de publicidad
para ser permiten unos momentos es ir a
volvemos
[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología cada semana les
traemos los descubrimientos
protagonistas e innovaciones que
sorprenden al mundo el futurista
vehículo es capaz de despegar y
aterrizar verticalmente los últimos
desarrollos tecnológicos y científicos y
su impacto en nuestro futuro
[Música]
acompáñenme en la crónica de ciencia y
tecnología por france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]
porque la historia se escribe día a día
porque la actualidad no espera la
información dondequiera que esté en
cualquier circunstancia
todos los temas para entender el mundo
para imaginar el mundo
france24 una mirada diferente liberté
égalité actually team
[Música]
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
hablando de un tema realmente
apasionante el metaverso todo este mundo
inmersivo del que bueno la verdad es que
mis colaboradores hoy me están ayudando
a entender bastante bien estamos
hablando antes de la pausa de ese cambio
de nombre de facebook que introduce todo
esto el cambio a meta que se debe este
cambio de nombre ven llama se debe a se
debe a una necesidad se debe a una
necesidad porque tal como lo estabas
diciendo facebook estaba en un momento
crítico critic y ximo o sea al tope y
tenía que cambiar de imagen de marca
para conseguir otra vez
involucrar la planeta entera en un
proyecto global por lo tanto ha escogido
un meta veréis guay quiere decir que
cuando cuando lo piensas piensas a algo
superior hay una evolución
yo hablo el bruc en el brou en israel
mena quiere decir muriendo se murió es
divertido de ver la analogía y de ver de
una empresa como facebook no lo ha
pensado no lo han llegado pero también
nos puedes dejar pensar a los filósofos
un poquito críticos de esto decir que la
meta es el principio de la muerte humana
hay mucha gente que sirve de esta
analogía de las palabras en el grupo
para dar su visión del meta también lo
que pasa de lo que nos está vendiendo
mark zuckerberg también pues viene hoy
en la prensa estos días hasta qué punto
esto está tan preparado hasta este punto
porque claro el momento coincide con una
crisis de facebook lo que no sabemos
hasta qué punto está anunciando algo
para lo que aún queda mucho poco israel
lo interesante aquí es que facebook ha
cambiado de nombre y se ha apropiado o
se ha subido a una ola de la que él no
es digamos el precursor es decir él
quiere crear un metaverso con sus
productos para que pueda tener una
vigencia todavía en el mundo digital no
porque pues hay mucha gente que ya no
usa facebook sobre todo los jóvenes y el
metaverso va a impactar sobre todo a las
generaciones pues recientes la gente que
utiliza el metaverso es gente joven
gente de menos de 18 años que están
mucho más familiarizadas con estas
tecnologías pero pues también este
cambio hacia de nombre viene pues con
una mala reputación que tiene facebook
no y también por tantos problemas de
privacidad cómo va a cómo gestionar tus
datos privados qué es lo que hace cómo
te tráquea cómo utiliza el pixel y creo
que facebook lo está haciendo más bien
para subirse en una ola que pues pues él
quiere reinventar y creo que tiene este
este poder de tener muchísimos usuarios
y masificar una práctica que ahorita es
digamos
como bueno voy a decir que a mí a mi
juicio la el tema para por facebook es
realmente los jóvenes es decir que
nuestro totalmente de acuerdo en el tema
de que los jóvenes no utilizan facebook
nomás porque utilizan instagram que es
parte claro de facebook y también siguen
utilizando en la organización de fiestas
y los mensajes en messenger así que
siguen siendo conectando y
aunque no miran a lo que les presenta
facebook todavía facebook recupera datos
datos personales informaciones
y ahí hay algo muy importante para
facebook de seguir siendo la primera
empresa social del mundo no y el meta es
la última tentativa
yo creo que tienen un mundo real
algo que algo que cambiar en su manera
de funcionar porque la gente
se pierde la confianza y la confianza
solamente y será una vez solamente se da
una vez efectivamente podríamos decir
que el metal o eso estamos no sé si es
decir mucho o no ante un tipo de
transhumancia
puede amanecer puede parecer de la
manera más o menos es un poquito fuerte
pero puede parecer
no me mojar ya tonto pero es facebook lo
vende como por fin puedes estar la
persona que siempre haces has soñado
estar o sea en facebook de vende como la
mejor persona de ti y en estos mundos
puedes estar el que siempre ha soñado
estar quien nunca has podido estar hasta
hoy en el mundo real es también muy
aspiracional respecto a muy capitalista
quiero decir que en el metal puede hacer
carlos
te dejo las y ahora mismo no hace falta
irnos al meta si quieres pues hablemos
de eso de las aspiraciones y de los
deseos preguntas que se pueden hacer
ahora mismo los telespectadores cómo
hacer el sexo en el metaverso cómo va a
ser el sexo vamos a tener relaciones
sexuales en el metaverso no me sorprende
que tienes esa pregunta que él cree pero
pero ese es un verdadero tema es que
cómo se va a transformar no solamente la
experiencia sino también los
sentimientos porque facebook nos dice
que va a ser también una experiencia
psicológica en el metaverso
eso a mí me asusta mucho que una máquina
puedes reproducir algo de psicología o
de la sexualidad o quizás no sé tomar
drogas o drogas vamos vamos a plantear
todo el mal por ejemplo cómo va a ser el
mal en el metaverso basta los crímenes
se puede matar en el metaverso va a
estar perseguido es que se abrieron una
cantidad no sea arrogante si nos
relacionamos a los que hizo facebook en
tema de por ejemplo de falsa
informaciones o de violencia
eso tiene que asustarnos
israel yo creo que más que hablar de lo
de las malas cosas son los crímenes que
se puedan hacer en el metaverso también
hay que ver cómo pues las consecuencias
que van a tener en nuestra manera de
socializar en la manera de interactuar
con las demás personas o sea como por
ejemplo no sé una podemos hablar de
intoxicación digital hasta qué punto voy
a estar conectado en el metaverso cuánto
tiempo le voy a dedicar y creo que no sé
por ejemplo en el desarrollo del
metaverso en china esto provoca ciertas
limitaciones porque hay regular por
ejemplo dicen que los niños no pueden
pasar más de tantas horas en conectados
a internet y que ponen limitantes a las
empresas chinas que van a desarrollar
este tipo de universos porque pues la
idea es que estés en el metaverso que
estés allí durante mucho mayor tiempo y
bueno también son como algunas de las
limitantes pero estamos hablando de una
infraestructura supranacional es la
pregunta que nos llega a la mente es las
luchas por el control de este tipo de
infraestructura podría agravar aún más
los conflictos globales que ya tenemos
en el planeta
buena mamá
y
seguramente porque la cada vez que damos
a los seres humanos una manera de
amplificar sus voces en sus acciones e
influencias e influencia el problema no
es tan que damos una manera de aumentar
las voces sino que se hace con un
algoritmo con un programa informático
del cual no sabemos nada claro no
sabemos cómo funciona y la democracia es
un sistema que requiere la transparencia
que requiere que los ciudadanos sean
capaces de hacerse su propia idea en las
cosas mi problema es que quien nos va a
decir que esté metaverso no es como un
coche que anda a 200 kilómetros por hora
y que no tiene frenos queremos este
coche nuestras frutas no creo que
tengamos lo que me permite estoy
totalmente de acuerdo contigo pero lo
bueno en la gracia de esto es lo que la
tecnología que está detrás y la
tecnología que está detrás es la block
change
es una tecnología que permite la
transparencia total de todo lo que está
dentro que permite de quitar el curso de
conciencia es decir que todo el mundo
puede tener acceso a justamente lo como
la manera de cómo está desarrollado a
las transacciones que están llevando
dentro de esta plataforma y por tema de
transparencia la tecnología usando
detrás del meta bears es totalmente
sinónimo de transparencia para que se
hagan una idea un dato más de lo que va
a mover todo este mundo del metaverso
bloomberg intelligence cifra el negocio
del meta ver son unos 8 800 mil millones
de dólares para 2024 2024 es mañana por
la mañana dicen también que dentro de
cinco años 50 por ciento del tráfico en
internet será un tráfico en el web 3.0
en el metaverso los mismos que decían
hace cinco años que en 2021 80 por
ciento del web será vídeo
hoy en día en 2021 el 82 por ciento del
web
vídeo los mismos predican que en cinco
años la mitad del web será metaverso y
es por eso que por ejemplo vamos a ver
yo creo que en un futuro así como vimos
con el surgimiento de facebook
pues todos los community managers y todo
eso yo creo que vamos a tener shift meta
bears officers que se van a encargar de
desarrollar los meta universos de cada
marca y es por eso que por ejemplo marca
las marcas como nike de marcas de ropa
incluso marcas de animales de mascotas
ya están creando sus metales porque han
visto el potencial comercial que tiene
también este tipo de tecnología no hoy
por ejemplo si tú eres alérgico a un
gato pues vas a tener un menta versión
de vas a poder comprar tu gatito darle
de comer comprarle su ropa que pues es
una ropa digital no existe y te permite
tener este tipo de interacciones
entonces creo que también es un y es por
eso que yo creo que facebook también se
está metiendo en este tipo de cosas
porque ellos sé que ellos tienen la data
tienen las inversiones tienen la manera
de penetrar pero también tienen la
manera de popularizar este tipo de
tecnologías entonces creo que
comercialmente también es súper súper
interesante hay mucha gente que está
invirtiendo que está desarrollando tipo
de tecnologías y creo que por allí va un
poco la cosa comercial lo
toma no hay algo que es muy una
verdadera sorpresa cuando se interesa en
meterse que nos explicaba antes del del
show benjamin es que el nudo lo juego
vídeo cuando estabas rico
la plata no era nada no no era era
virtual ahora sí está fresco en el
metaverso está sectores de la verdad
real claro eso cambia totalmente nuestra
relación con estos universos virtuales
porque si en un universo virtual puedes
enriquecerte así que es verdadero es que
hasta ahora tenemos claro que nuestra
identidad era la real que el mundo
virtual estaba ahí pero es que a partir
del metaverso se abre que nuestra
identidad real en realidad son las dos
no sé incluso puede que más la virtual
hay una deshumanización en cualquier
caso no sé cómo los seres humanos
cada uno de nosotros va a
hacer su vida
siendo dos personas distintas hay algo
que realmente en medicina es claro
y una caja de pandora que aún no hemos
destapado hoy porque ya se nos acaba el
tiempo pero hablar de los conflictos
mentales que puede suponer todo esto me
imagino y si
además de esto también la vinculación de
nuestra realidad es decir que si tienes
dos seres humanos dentro de ti y que
estos seres humanos no son
conectados con la misma cosa no tienen
la misma información todo puede cambiar
se me acaba el tiempo muchísimas gracias
a los tres por haberme acompañado hoy
hemos aprendido muchísimo hablando hoy
de este nuevo mundo el futuro que ya es
presente el metaverso a todos ustedes
hasta la próxima semana quien en primera
plana gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]